[Music]
and get over yourself new bridge over
and get all that right already submitted
by David is da best hi he's not here so
that makes me the but you still the best
by D for the past oh my god you suck
he's [ __ ] [ __ ] of all days I've been
telling it
no he's got negative nine yeah exactly
a female passenger with a PhD blasted an
airline after they addressed her as miss
instead of dr. world can I see a picture
of this video because I feel like it's
doctor it's dr. T that's incredible I
picture a British [ __ ] insecure his
book [ __ ] are people supposed to know
she has a name tag the [ __ ] says
doctor on her ticket on a plane ticket
you can you can tell them you want to
have doctor if you get like a if you get
like a first first class for Singapore
Airlines right yeah you can you can
choose your title whether it's King sir
[ __ ] ranking yes like King [ __ ]
put in all that [ __ ] yeah you could put
in whatever title it's cool that you're
gonna have to call you King whatever for
the for the whole flight and they know
your name in first class there so like
when you come up to them yeah they
already say your name and [ __ ] Singapore
Airlines oh but you it's like they're
they're special [ __ ] room I think
that's every Oh probably I only done I
only done one I've never had any
business class addressing attorneys well
if I put a title and it's in the form
they better address me by that even if I
ruin yeah there's like just as you did
Southwest business okay
yeah you're right it's like choose your
own business class no I choose your own
seat Spirit Airlines maybe yeah Spirit
Airlines business class is they don't
slip it on you while you get on the
plane they don't tell you they hate you
while you're bored yeah what's the woods
below economy Oh [ __ ] cargo yeah yeah
that's where they put the cats in the
dog yeah yeah so spirit is cargo it's
all gardening yeah yeah it's like those
Rambo movies where you're in the [ __ ]
plane with a cow and a chicken and
you're just like is that the part of the
plan where the animals are freezing are
they overheat we're and one animal
Huddle's up to one side of the cage the
other animal calls up the other side the
cage did blow trying to work each other
with her body is this the first thinking
three mil agree she has a PhD so she's
not a medical doctor monsters wait so
she's not even a [ __ ] medical doctor
no but PhD is a doctor but like there's
a medical doctor she's a doctor but not
for medicine
yeah I'm saying amen I know wait so
she's a PhD she's not even a real doctor
are you kidding she's a real doctor
though it's not a physician but if you
have a side be a pH PhD I know we said
not a medical doctor right right she's a
doctor she received her doctor of
philosophy Oh philosophy nope nope all
right so this is what she tweeted hey at
quantis my name is dr. lo I love
contests doctor what does this dope
doctor this is dope dude
[Laughter]
you know I usually have a lot of
patience but today today doing so good -
[Laughter]
okay I care okay you're okay
I like a blouse it's so nice it's very
cute on you typically you look so pretty
but that's still interrupting all right
so she said hey Quan says my name is dr.
o dari my ticket says dr. dark dari do
not look at my ticket look at me look
back at my ticket decide to decide it's
a typo and call me Miss odary I did not
spend eight years at university to be
called Smith how is she so sure that
that person decided that it was a typo
like that is something she drew I mean
she should use her doctor's skills and
critical thinking skills to realize that
that is an imaginary thought that she
had in her own mind
this started so [ __ ] funny so a lot
of people are like if you went to
medical school you are doctor or dari if
you have a PhD you are say obon her
first name o dari PhD and you have a
doctorate degree you are not however a
doctor as understood by society and you
shouldn't feel free to steal the title
claimed centuries ago by the medical
profession that's what one person
replied that's a hoax right back to
Sharia back so she kept getting a little
bunch of backlash for that like saying
like wow all those years in school
didn't teach you how to be a decent
human all this [ __ ] nice damn so then
she did a follow up which says copying
so much flak for this tweet this was not
about my ego it was about highlighting
one of the thousand instances of sexism
that women encounter every day it's not
the title it's about the fact that this
wouldn't have happened if I was a man
how about how about classism [ __ ]
how much money does that person make who
you're scolding yeah like holy Sh I
didn't even see that as sexist like I
was [ __ ] I don't even know if it was a
man or a woman that called her miss I
don't know I saw it completely as
someone who felt entitled because they
went to school and got it I didn't get
it do they have this title so now they
want to be referred to as whatever and
they're [ __ ] angry because they're
like oh well you're not gonna call me by
my title that's like yeah it's like
yelling at a waitress for not getting
your title right and it's like somebody
who makes [ __ ] money compared to you and
you're better than them like already in
your own head and then you've got to
assert yourself over them well what the
philosophy doctorate I'm pretty sure the
the the flight attendant makes way more
would you type that out her thought was
like I went to school to not be caught
this when I go to the airport like get
the [ __ ] over yourself like this is not
that same aching it into a gender issue
- right and I think that she kind of did
that to like flip the switch after she
realized that she was looking entitled
yeah and also when you see a doctor and
you call them like whatever doctor
Garcia I would be like oh no call me
Jasmine you know like it's one of those
things where it's like you've got before
very comfortable in their position who
don't need to be called this and then
the people who are clearly very insecure
ego doubt that need to go by doctor yeah
I remember when I was a given a speech
at my
in my speech class like I didn't say a
President Bush I said Bush right and
when I was doing and in the teacher was
like excuse me it's President Bush you
must address to him by his proper title
Wow
and I was like I didn't know that it was
offensive to say interesting like that's
so technically if they're in office
you're supposed to say that and I think
all those Secretary of Defense treasurer
whatever all those [ __ ] are
supposed to say honorable mister or
missus whatever at the end at the time
in office there's like a specific way to
address them suppose it's supposed to
never just well you never been in a
formal set
so if you're just talking with your home
is like whatever you know but then I
felt like us if you're delivering a
speech at City Hall or like a speech in
class which is you're in a Senate
hearing it's like the Honorable mr.
pumpkin whatever the [ __ ] it's so lame
in parliamentary I hate all that [ __ ] I
don't like any sort of royalty title
surname [ __ ] I just think I only like it
if it's for me yeah exactly I like the
old ones like [ __ ] sire and me Lord I
do count is the six well count that's
the sickest one tunt the Duke of
Nottingham there's other person reply
pathetic so she got even more [ __ ] okay
so then people responded don't think
it's got anything to do it to do about
being a woman in a man's world being a
doctor is a job Hetal it's not your name
someone else said I never walked around
demanding to be called nurse Rae
everywhere I was working retired now you
need to get your own self-importance
people that are like CEOs like please
its CEO geo and Bart like buy your
tights it's not that [ __ ] serious
it's I don't even want people to know
that I own it
exactly half the time you don't even
want it that's why just act like a clown
all the [ __ ] time what I can't be an
entrepreneur yeah I make funny videos I
don't mind if people who refer to me as
your lordship or something or your
majesty or the benevolent and Empire
Empire and the sad thing no the sad
thing is when you have to tell people
what your title is or you have to tell
people how famous you are where it's
like one very big on YouTube it's like I
know you then man yeah like you know I
mean like just [ __ ] relax a little
bit
like it's the people people would
actually accomplish it and people were
actually dope it [ __ ] everyone knows who
you are already yeah it's like LeBron
James LeBron James doesn't have to
explain to everybody that he's a famous
basketball right yeah he's already
LeBron James you know unless until ten
years from now he's selling Gold Bond
and he's like hi remember me
James have you noticed that killing yeah
the general yep he's like I'm Shaquille
O'Neal and I you got a by icy hot you
gotta [ __ ] buy it look I got alimony
you've got a by icy hot
please Christ I saw this recent bootleg
as commercial of all the like doctors
like like what's his name you know Neil
Patrick Harris [ __ ] some of the cast
from yeah yeah and it's like a insurance
company your health care company or
whatever and I'm like wow dude like
everyone hit an all-time new low or
these guys have so much money now that
they can afford these doctors
dramatically afford these actors Neil
Batman bridges [ __ ] yeah so they could
afford him commercial was so ghetto
though it looked like a [ __ ] a local
commercial probably just like reached
out to all of them and offered them
something low and maybe they were just
like [ __ ] could we all get to work
together we all love each other let's
just do this for shits and giggles there
were from all like different shows and
they were all doctors on all right no I
know about I haven't seen it but maybe
to them they were like who cares it
seems like a fun they probably got a
million each some sure yeah cuz I don't
ever believe anyone does a commercial
for [ __ ] singles no way I remember daddy
got like two million for the Proactiv
campaign thingamabob er but I wonder
what two million is in terms of their
value like I wonder if that's actually
at value if it's too high if it's too
low like what did he it seems like times
are rough because if you're that big and
you're doing these kind of commercials
I'm like would Brett Favre's tell me to
buy gold I know there's trouble brewing
you know Sam yeah Brett Favre famous
quarterback like well legendary
quarterback and he's in like every other
he's in like all the jeans commercials
for I don't know whatever the [ __ ] and
then he's like you gotta buy a gold now
so I'm like oh man these guys didn't
probably probably see the money pretty
much know you can always tell wait did
he did he did proactive video did he
just go Simpson I forgot who I was a
bunch of other people with Eber I said
it he did
no I don't know but I saw him y'all get
practice who's that like um he's an IG
kid - Cameron Cameron oh yeah he did -
geez Louise I thought practive was like
you know like when you would go to the
mall and there's like those people that
try to sell you hair straighteners
that's like what the category that I put
Proactiv it yeah baby they had a hell of
money though yeah have you heard of
University Phoenix yeah oh yeah cuz
that's one of those things which is an
online course yeah but they have a [ __ ]
ton of money so they sponsored an entire
stadium for the Arizona Cardinals is the
University of Phoenix Stadium and it
makes them sound look legit as [ __ ] but
they just lost the naming rights but
they had a flick 10 years that's crazy
do you know where they lost them I don't
think they probably ran out of money
[Music]